PROFESSOR: The topic of this
chapter is finding trellis
representations for block codes,
in particular linear
block codes.
We're looking only at binary
block codes, except one of the
homework problems looks at MDS
codes over ground field of q.
The principles are the same for
general Fq or in fact for
group codes.
We're looking for minimal
trellis representations.
And so just to review our line
of thought, basically we
proved a basic theorem called
the state space theorem that
tells us that there is a vector
space over the ground
field at any time which we can
identify with the state space.
It has a certain dimension.
And we got a little formula in
terms of subcodes for the
dimension of the state space.
We set up a little generator
matrix where we isolated the
past part of the code with
respect to a certain cut time
future part of the code,
generators for that.
We subtract those
generators out.
What's left?
The number of generators is the
number of generators it
takes to generate the state
space, in other words the
dimension of the state space.
So we got a theorem on the
dimension of the state space
at any time.
And then we found a nifty little
algorithm to find a --
to determine the dimensions of
the state spaces at all times,
the minimal state spaces.
And in fact we can use this
algorithm to construct a
minimal trellis realization.
The algorithm involves a
trellis-oriented generator matrix.
And the idea here turns
out to be very simple.
All you do is you find any
generator matrix for your
linear block code, and
you reduce it to
trellis-oriented form.
Trellis-oriented form means that
the generators have as
short a span as possible.
It's a minimum span
generator matrix.
And we do that just in a greedy
fashion by any time we
have an opportunity to add two
generators together such that
either their starting position
cancels, or their end position
cancels, we do it.
And out of that we get a shorter
generator, and we can
replace one of the two
generators in the
combination by that.
We can keep shortening
everything up.
The algorithm must terminate at
the point where no further
shortening is possible.
And that is explicitly the
point at which all the
starting times of the generators
are different, and
all the ending times of all the
generators are different.
For example, here's a
trellis-oriented generator matrix.
The starting times,
the spans of the
generators, are like this.
The active times, starting
times --
there's the starting time of
this one, and its ending time.
Here's the starting time
of the next one,
and its ending time.
The starting time of the
next one, and its
ending time is here.
And the starting time
of this one, and its
ending time is here.
We're not always going to find
that the starting and ending
times are disjoint.
This happens, it turns
out, because this
is a self-dual code.
In a self-dual code, you will
always get this each time,
either a starting time
or an ending time.
But that's not a general
property.
For instance, another example
that we've used is, say, the 8
7 2 single parity check code.
What are its generators?
Its generators look like
this, dot, dot, dot,
down to 0, 0, 1, 1.
That's a set of trellis-oriented
generators
with starting time, ending
time, the first one here.
Starting time, ending time
of the second one there.
So in general for this one,
every time is a starting and
ending time up to here, where
every intermediate time is
both the starting and
an ending time.
So it could happen that way,
or another example would be
the 8 1 8 repetition code.
What's a trellis-oriented
generator matrix for that?
It only has one generator.
It looks like that.
It has a starting span
as the whole thing.
The starting time is here.
The ending time is here.
So for general codes, the
starting times and ending
times could be anywhere.
There will always
be k of them.
And otherwise, there's always
one at the beginning.
If it's a nontrivial code,
there's always an ending time
at the end, et cetera.
But this particular behavior
is for self-dual codes.
Anyway, having done that
we can now read off the
dimensions of the state spaces
by simply looking for how many
generators are active at
any particular time.
For a state space, we're always
looking at the times
between the symbols,
cut times.
We could in fact draw a trivial
one there, but we're
looking between here.
How many are active
at this time?
One.
So dimension of the state
space at state
time k is 1, 2, 3.
This point, we come
back to 2 again.
3, 2, 1, 0, 0 at the end.
It's always zero at the ends
because at that point
everything's in the future, or
everything is in the past.
So these are trivial
state spaces.
These are the nontrivial state
spaces in the trellis.
And in fact, you remember
we had a little picture.
We can draw this complete
trellis out with the state
spaces of size 1 2
4 8 4 8 4 2 1.
So this is called the state
dimension profile, just this
set, this ordered set.
Or the state space size profile
is 2 to the dimension,
of binary codes, whatever.
And similarly down here, if we
look at state space sizes, we
see the dimension is going
to be one at every time.
So in this case, the dimension
of the state space is 0, 1, 1,
1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 0.
And similarly down here, we
look at the cut time.
It cuts one active generator
every time.
So it's 0, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 0.
So we get at least the state
space dimensions just by
inspection of the
trellis-oriented generator matrix.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: We proved it
in several steps.
First we have the state space
theorem, which I gave to you
in the following form: the
dimension of the state space
at time k is equal to the
dimension of the code minus
the past subcode.
Let me write that.
The dimension of the past
subcode minus the dimension of
the future subcode at time k
relative to this cut time.
And we proved from the
trellis-oriented generator
matrix that the past subcode
is generated by all the
trellis-oriented generators that
have support on the past,
and the future by all
the ones that have
support on the future.
So, it's simply we
take those out.
And what do we have left?
We have the ones that are active
at time k, the ones
that are neither wholly
supported on the past nor on
the future.
They're supported both on
the past and future.
And those, that's what
this difference is.
So explicitly we have --
the code is generated
by all generators.
That's all k generators.
Cpk is generated by
trellis-oriented generators
supported on the past.
And Cfk is generated by the
trellis-oriented generators
supported on the future.
So the difference --
state code sk is generated
by the trellis-oriented
generators not supported
on past or future, or
active at time k.
Probably good to write all
that out at least once.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
self-dual codes all have such
properties that each time is
starting and ending?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why is that?
PROFESSOR: Why?
It's a duality theorem, and
we're not doing many duality
theorems in this course, so
I'll simply tell you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
has this property, it
must be a self-dual.
PROFESSOR: I don't think
that's true.
It's possible that's true.
Duality theorems are very
strong, but I don't think this
is a sufficient property.
For instance, suppose I just
changed one of the generators
to look like that.
It still has disjoint starting
and ending times, but now I
don't think the code
is self-dual.
So here's another code generated
by these four
generators, and I don't
believe self-dual.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm guessing
that it isn't.
To prove it I would compute
the dual code, and I would
find that it wasn't same
code, didn't have
the same code words.
But I'm guessing that if I just
make random changes in
the interior here, I'm not going
to get a self-dual code,
because that's a very strong
structural property.
But I'm not going to take the
time in class to do that.
But these are good questions.
The whole subject of duality
is a wonderful and elegant
topic that we just don't
have time to do
much in this course.
If I did it another time,
I could spend
many lectures on duality.
Some of the homework problems
have suggested what you might
be able to do in orthogonal
codes, but --
well, one of the problems you'll
do on the homework --
I was going to talk about
it a little later.
There's a dual state space
theorem that basically says
the state space sizes, or
dimensions, are the same for
the dual code as they are
for the primal code.
Here's one example.
Of course, dual is itself, so
it's trivial that the state
space size is the same.
But here's another less
trivial example.
These two codes are orthogonal
to each other.
And what is similar about
their trellises?
Their trellises are both
two-state trellises.
They don't look the same.
This trellis looks like this,
because they're all zeroes up
here, and all ones down here.
That's the repetition code
trellis, whereas this trellis
looks like this.
It has crosses every time and
so forth, abstractly.
So trellises are not the same.
They have different branching
properties, but the state
space sizes are the
same at all times.
This is a general property of
dual codes which you will
prove on the homework, if you
haven't done so already.
Sorry, it's hard to know what to
tell you about and what to
suppress, because I'm also
trying to cover more
material this year.
There's a lot of material that's
really nice that I have
to skip over.
Let's continue from this.
Let's make a minimal
realization.
So, a canonical minimal
trellis.
I'm doing this in a little bit
different order than it's done
in the notes, but I think you
will see this kind of argument
very quickly.
I've got this trellis-oriented
generator matrix, but suppose
I didn't know what the
trellis looked like.
I put it up the first
time last time.
But all I have is this generator
matrix, and I want
to generate a trellis now for
this code which has minimal
state spaces.
It's also going to turn out to
be minimal in every other way.
Well, let's start off
by realizing the
first generator here.
The first generator generates a
little one-dimensional code.
G1, the code generated by the
first generator, is simply the
two code words 0, 0, 0,
0, 1, 1, 1, 1, 0, 0.
So let me realize that little
one-dimensional code with a
minimal trellis for that.
What would it look like?
If I go through this, I'll
see that it has --
my trellis-oriented generator
matrix for this code is simply
1, 1, 1, 1, 0, 0, 0.
I see from that that the
dimensions of the state spaces
is 0, 1, 1, 1, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0.
And you can easily see that what
the trellis, the minimal
trellis, a minimal trellis looks
like is 0, 0, 0, 0, 1,
1, 1, 1, 0, 0, 0, 0.
So there is the minimal trellis
realization for that
one-dimensional code.
It has state spaces of
dimension 0, 1, 1,
1, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0.
Therefore the state spaces
are all minimal,
as proved from this.
It's all sort of elementary.
Similarly, I can realize this
one by another little machine
that looks like this.
0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0.
This is just the state
transition diagram of a linear
time-varying finite
state machine.
And it looks like that, and it
too is minimal by the same
argument for the one-dimensional
code generated
by this generator.
What is this saying here?
This is saying we really --
what we should imagine here
is we have a little memory
element that's only active at
state times 1, 2, and 3.
So to realize this, this is a
one-dimensional memory element.
Think of it as a little --
well, a memory for
an element of f2.
It's active during the interval
1 through 3, during
the time that this generator
is active.
It's active at these three
times, not otherwise.
So you can think of it
as just disappearing.
It comes into existence
at time 1.
It holds whatever the
input bit is.
Think of --
we're trying to create the
code as the set of all --
sum of ui gi.
And so what this memory element
really does is it
holds ui during the time that
it's needed, which is at times
1, 2, and 3.
Whatever the coefficient is --
what could it be, 0 or 1?
Element of the base field, f2.
So the memory element holds, it
contains u1 in this case.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What if we look at
this matrix only for the
second code.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So that will give
0, 1, 0, 1, 1, 0, 1, 0.
PROFESSOR: Correct.
AUDIENCE: So some places it
will suggest that the
dimension is --
PROFESSOR: The fact that
the values are --
there will always be 1 here at
the starting time and the
ending time.
Otherwise we wouldn't
draw a branch there.
But they can be arbitrary
in between.
So don't be thrown off by the
fact that there are some 0
values in here.
What we're doing here is we're
realizing u2 times g2, where
u2 can be either 0 or 1.
And g2 can be arbitrary, except
that it has a starting
time and an ending
time, so it's not
arbitrary for this kind.
AUDIENCE: What if we try
to find the state space
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: For this, what I
need is a one-dimensional
memory element containing u2
which is active during a
different interval,
2 through 6.
So think of these as like
little stars that
wink on or wink off.
This thing comes into
existence for three
consecutive times, and
then it disappears.
This thing comes into existence
for five consecutive
times, and then it disappears.
Because those are the only
times when it's needed to
contribute to the output.
So altogether, we can think of
there as sort of being four
memory elements which contain
u1, u2, u3, and u4.
And we form the outputs g1k
times this, sort of like in
the convolutional code.
g2k g3k and g4k.
The generators step along in
time, and we form the outputs.
We sum this all together in a
summer, and this provides yk,
the output, as we go from k
equals 1 through 8 as we go
through the code word.
But we only need this one
for -- it's only on from
time 1, 2, and 3.
And this is on from
time 2 through 6.
time 3 through 5.
And this is on from
time 4 through 7.
Because we don't need
it any other time.
So you can think of an input
coming in at time 1, at the
starting time of the first
generator, being saved for as
long as it's needed, then
it's discarded.
And in fact we don't need that
memory element anymore.
How many people are
getting this?
Raise your hand if
you get this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's a time --
what I'm trying to do is draw
a time-varying machine.
So how do I do that?
At time 1, it looks like this.
Time 1, it just has u1,
and we multiply it by
g11, which is 1.
And that gives me the
output at time 1.
There's nothing else
that contributes.
At time 2, we've got now another
input, u1 and u2.
And we've got to sum the
contributions from both of
those, times their respective
coefficients.
At time 3, we're up to
three of them, and
we need all of them.
We're going to form some linear
combination according
to the generator matrix.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's time-varying,
yeah.
So get used to it.
For a block code it obviously
has to be time-varying.
Obviously if we regard these as
impulse responses, this is
the impulse response to u1.
It only lasts in terms of symbol
times from time 0 1 2
3, for four time units
of symbol time.
This is the impulse
response to u2.
u2 you can think of as an input
that comes in at time 2,
and whose output rings
for five more times.
So you need to save u2 for five
more times, and then it
disappears.
We don't need to save
it anymore.
We can let it drop off
the end of the shift
register, if you like.
u3 comes in at time 3, and this
is its impulse response.
And u4 comes in at time 5, and
this is its impulse response.
Does that help?
How many people are not
getting it now?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: We don't need it
here, but we're going to need
it again at time 4, so
we have to save it.
What are you going to do
with it at time 3?
You going to hide
it somewhere?
So I still need to save it.
This, again, is linear system
theory, except I guess you
just don't get taught linear
system theory anymore.
But this is what you have
to do if you --
before, for convolutional codes,
we did linear systems
theory for linear time-invariant
systems.
They have to be over a finite
field, but who cares?
We did general linear
system theory.
This is general linear system
theory for realizing
time-varying systems.
In fact, one comment that might
be good to make at this
point is that --
now go back and remember
what we did with
convolutional codes.
We started out with a rate 1
over n convolutional code c,
and we found some generator
for it.
Basically we can take any code
word in the code, and all of
its shifts will generate
the code.
Any non-zero code word, all of
its time shifts generate the
convolutional code.
So take any code word g of d in
a convolutional code, and g
of d, dg of d, d squared
g of d and so forth
generate the code.
But then we converted it by
doing a little polynomial or
Laurent series algebra.
We took a rational one and we
converted it to a canonical
one, g prime of d.
Which if you remember, this is
the polynomial code word of
minimum degree in the code.
We call that degree nu.
What were we doing there?
The shifts of g prime of d
form a trellis-oriented
generator matrix for this
convolutional code.
For instance, for our canonical
example, g prime of
d looked like this.
Polynomial notation, it's 1 plus
d squared 1 plus d plus d
squared is the generator
matrix.
Let me write that out as 1, 1
at time 0 or coefficient 0.
0, 1, 1, 1, and then all
0's before that, and
all 0's after that.
Is somebody sleeping?
Wake him up please, before
I turn around.
What?
Oh, all right.
I'm very glad to hear that.
So here is g prime of d
written out as bits.
dg prime of d looks like what?
It looks like the same thing
shifted over one.
d squared g prime of d looks
like this and so forth.
Is this trellis-oriented?
In this case, each time interval
contains two symbols.
Here are our divisions
between symbols.
We've got a rate 1/2 code, so
we chose to take them two
symbols at a time.
Where are the starting
and ending times?
This one starts here,
ends here.
Starts here, ends here.
So all the starting times and
ending times are different.
Ergo, this is a
trellis-oriented generator matrix.
Modulo some hand-waving about
infinite sequences.
Ergo, we ought to be able to use
the state space theorem to
say what are the state
space sizes.
Any time I have a cut here,
what are the spans?
The spans are like there,
there, there, so forth.
So the state space dimension at
each time is going to be 2,
2, 2, 2, 2.
And if we go through this
construction procedure, what
are we going to get?
We're going to get something
that at time 0, we need to
have in memory, we need
to remember u minus
1 and u minus 2.
At time 1, just doing what I did
up here, we need to have
in memory u minus 1 and u0.
At time 2, we need to have
in memory u0 and u1.
And we achieve that just
by implementing this
with a shift register.
In the time-invariant case it's
very easy, and you all
understand it.
So exactly the same theory goes
through for rate 1 over n
convolutional codes.
I will tell you briefly that to
treat rate k over n, it's
basically just the same thing,
except we need k generators
starting at each time here.
But in order to get a canonical
encoder, we just get
a trellis-oriented generator
matrix again.
And by the way, modulo this
hand-waving about infinite
sequences, I've now proved what
I asserted, that this
encoder is minimal among all
encoders for this code, that
it has the minimum number
of memory elements.
Because from this argument,
the minimal state space
dimension at each time is 2
once I've achieved this
canonical trellis-oriented
generator matrix.
By the way, this theory
is very general.
It's really all you need to know
to do minimal realization
theory of linear systems,
whether they're time-varying
or time-invariant over any
field, or over groups.
So that was a parenthetical
comment about convolutional
codes just to tie it back
to what we did in
the previous chapter.
I haven't completed
what I wanted to
say about block codes.
How am I going to do this
without erasing something?
Let's go back to block codes.
And I guess I'll move over.
The point that I was in the
process of making was that I
can realize each one of these
generators individually by a
little trellis diagram that's
one-dimensional during the
time that the generator is
active, and zero-dimensional
state space during the time
the generator is inactive.
And think of this as just
one component here.
To generate a code word,
a particular code
word is just the sum.
All I need to do is sum the
outputs of all these
generators independently.
How many different possibilities
are there?
There are 2 to the k possible
code words.
Each one of these generates
one of two
possible code words.
If I take the set of all
possible sums of these four
code words, I'm going to have
16 possible code words.
So that very quickly was what
I was doing when I said,
here's a little machine that
generates the first code, c1.
Here's a little machine that
generates the second code, c2.
Only has two possible code words
according to the value
of what's in storage.
This generates the
third component.
fourth component.
Sum it all together,
and you get --
sorry, I'm calling this y now. y
equals the sum of the ui gi.
You see that?
I hope I've beaten it into
the ground enough now.
So it's a linear time-varying
machine.
That is a realization of it,
if you've understood my
description of it now.
And now we can draw
the trellis of it.
That what can happen at time
1, we can either have u1.
Now I can label my states
here, at this time u1.
u1 can be either 0 or 1.
This is u1.
At time 2, I have both u1
and u2 in my state.
So this can either be 0, 0
or 0, 1, or 1, 0 or 1, 1.
And obviously if I've already
determined u1 is 0 here, it's
still going to be 0 at time 2.
I label these with their
associated outputs.
This is 1.
This is also 1.
This can turn it back to 0.
And I just keep going.
At the third time, I
have u1, u2, u3.
I have eight states.
At time 4, I come back.
I only have u2, u3 at time
4, and so these merge.
So I get something --
this doesn't merge like
that, though.
It merges down here.
0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 1.
This merges to 0, 1 when
I drop the first one.
It's probably worth doing
this more carefully
than I'm doing it.
0, 1 can go to 0, 1,
0, or 0, 1, 1.
0, 1, 0 can either go to --
u2 equals 1.
I guess these can't cross.
u2 --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Excuse me?
u3 and u4.
PROFESSOR: No, this
is state time.
State time 1, 2, 3.
u4 hasn't started yet.
So I'm sorry, this
is 5 through 7.
Is that right?
It only lasts for
three intervals.
So I only have u2, u3.
u1, u2 has to be 0, 0, 1, so
this would then go to 0, 1.
0, 1.
These seem to cross.
Yes, they do cross.
So let's see if I can actually
complete it.
This could go to 1,
0, 0, or 1, 0, 1.
And then this one goes up
to either 0, 0 or 0, 1.
This one can go to 1,
1, 0 or 1, 1, 1.
And that can go like this.
So there's the trellis
for the first half.
It's topologically the same, but
looks a little different
from what I put up before.
I interchanged these two with
these two, and this
one with this one.
But you can recover the trellis
that I had before.
In any case, I claim when I've
labeled this with what the
appropriate output is
at each time, I've
got my minimal trellis.
And now we can make more
comments about
how the trellis works.
You see that whenever a
generator starts, we have
what's called a divergence in
the trellis, a branching
process, a branching out,
whereas whenever a generator
ends, we have a convergence
in.
So a starting time --
if we have a generator starting,
then we get a branch
that looks like this, like
here, and here, and here.
When we have an ending time,
we have branches that look
like this, like here.
So this is a starting time,
starting time, starting time,
and ending time.
So this tells you when things
open and close in the trellis.
Now again, as I've said for
these more general trellises,
down here we can have starting
and ending at the same time.
And in that case,
we get a cross.
We get a starting and ending
at the same time, we get
something that looks
like this.
And if we get neither starting
nor ending, empty, then
nothing happens.
We just get --
the trellis segment looks like
that, like this one here.
In this case we have a starting
time, an ending time
in this trellis.
Here we have nothing
happening.
So you just get an extension,
a parallel extension where
nothing happens.
So again, the starting and
ending times tell you what
happens in the trellis.
There's one other thing that you
can read from the trellis,
which is the size of
branch spaces.
And since as usual I'm running
a little later
than I intend to --
let me just state without proof
that there is a similar
theorem for branch spaces.
What is a branch?
When we look in a trellis, a
branch is one of these things.
That's a branch.
What do we need to
define a branch?
We have a initial state, the
code output at time k.
We're calling that y time
k in the next state.
So it's that triple.
Again, this is linear
system theory.
State, output, next state.
Those are the three things
that define a branch.
This branch is state 1 0.
Output whatever it is, y k,
and next state 1 0 0.
And that differentiates it
from this down here.
If we define the branch
as this triple,
then we can add triples.
States form a vector space
over the ground field.
These are simply symbols
These are vectors over
the ground field.
So we can add them.
And we find that it's closed,
and the set of all branches is
a vector space.
It's fairly easy to show.
Look at the notes, but it's
basically because these are
all projected from code words
in the first place, and code
words form a vector space, so
this is just a projection of
the code words, a certain kind
of projection onto the state
spaces and symbol spaces
and so forth.
A projection of a vector space
is a vector space.
Roughly the proof.
And what is the dimension
of the branch space?
Again, I'm just going to
give you the answer.
Suppose we have a
trellis-oriented generator matrix.
Let's suppose we want to find
out the size of the branch
space at this time.
What doesn't enter into
the branch space?
What doesn't make a difference
to the branches?
All the pasts that arrive at the
same state at time k are
equivalent.
So this generator doesn't
enter in.
All the futures that depart from
time k plus 1 don't enter
in, so anything that's supported
by the future at
time k plus 1 doesn't
enter in.
And what's left is all of the
generators that are active at
symbol time k.
Notice the symbol times occur
between the state times.
So certainly this
is an easy --
this is one of those results
that's easier to understand
than to prove, and I'll refer
you to the notes to prove.
The dimension of the branch
space is simply the number of
generators that are active
at symbol time k.
Because branches are
synchronized with the symbol
times, not with the
state times.
So how does that come
out over here?
There's the dimension of the
branch space is 1 here.
It's 2 here.
It's 3 here.
It's 4 here.
I'm sorry, it's 3 again here.
This one hasn't started yet.
It's 3 again here.
It's 3 again here,
2 here, 1 here.
That means that the size of the
branch space is 2, 4, 8,
8, 8, 8, 4, 2.
Is that right?
There are two branches here.
There are four branches here.
There are eight branches here.
There are still eight
branches here.
And it's symmetric on
the other side.
So it looks like we got the
right answer there, and in
fact it's a general rule.
So that's great.
That's another property of
trellis-oriented generator matrix.
We can again, by inspection, get
the dimensions of all the
branch space sizes.
Are the branch sizes
important?
Yes.
In fact, they're more important
from a complexity
point of view than the
state space sizes.
95% of the literature has
to do with state spaces.
State space is a little bit more
elegant mathematically.
For instance, you don't have the
same kind of dual branch
space theorem as you have a
dual state space theorem.
But actually, when you're asking
what's going on in the
Viterbi algorithm, what
does the Viterbi
algorithm have to do?
At a minimum, it has to do one
thing for each branch.
It has to perform a metric
extension, a metric addition
computation at least once
for each branch.
So the Viterbi algorithm
complexity is better estimated
by the size of the branch space
than the size of the
state space.
To progress at this point, a
Viterbi algorithm has to do at
least eight things.
To progress again, it has to
do at least eight things.
So it's more relevant from the
point of view of complexity.
Furthermore, you can play games
with state space size.
And you've seen me play games
For instance, if I draw this
as a two-section trellis --
the first picture I put up was
only a four-state trellis, and
it looked like this.
I went immediately
to time 2, and I
aggregated these two things.
0, 0 and 1, 1 were up
here, and 0, 1 and
1, 0 were down here.
And then I had a nice --
I just drew these four
states over here.
And if I do it like that, then
I get a much nicer picture.
It looks like this.
It looks only like a
four-state trellis.
Now, is this still a
legitimate trellis?
Yeah, it's still a legitimate
trellis.
If I do a Viterbi algorithm
decoding of this trellis, is
it any different from this?
Well, in detail it is a
little bit different.
You do the additions and the
comparisons and the selection.
So you only do selections
every this often.
And if you think about it,
it's really legitimate to
think of this --
if you think exactly how the
Viterbi algorithm works,
really what's it doing?
It's not making any
selection here.
It's just adding an increment
there, and then adding another
increment, and it's not
making any selection
until it gets here.
So it's perfectly legitimate to
think of this as basically
being a four-state algorithm.
It really isn't doing any
work at this stage.
All the work occurs at this
stage if you think about the
operation of the Viterbi
algorithm.
So this is a quite legitimate
representation.
And so what are we
going to say?
Is the state complexity of this
code, is it four states
or is it eight states?
Well, to some degree it's just
a matter of definition.
How do you choose
to define it?
If you want something more
fundamental, it's better to go
to branch complexity.
What's the branch complexity
here for the
fully displayed trellis?
It's eight.
By branch complexity, I
mean the maximum size
of any branch space.
What's the branch
complexity here?
It's eight.
We've still got eight.
Ultimately we've got to compare
these eight things and
reduce them to four, whether
we do it here or here.
I gave you another trellis which
was only a two-section
trellis, where I just showed
the four central states.
And we actually have two
branches going there, two
branches going there, and two
branches going there.
What's the branch complexity
of that trellis?
Still eight.
There are eight ways to get
from the origin to here.
If you go back to how we do this
theorem, if you believe
this theorem, what happens now
if we say arbitrarily, OK,
we're going to define the state
spaces as we do in a
rate 1/2 convolutional code.
We're just going to define
the state times to
be every two times.
Then the dimension of the state
spaces, just at those
times we've defined,
is 0, 2, 2, 2, 0.
They don't change.
We just have fewer of
them by our choice.
What happens to the dimensions
of the branch spaces?
Again, if the theorem is
correct, we should just count
the number of active generators
at each now of
these four bi-symbol times.
So it's 2, 3, 3, 2.
Is that right?
That is the branch complexity
of this trellis down here.
It's 4 in the initial interval,
and 8 over here.
So again it's correct.
Suppose we go to that so-called
two-section trellis.
We just say there's a first
half and a second half.
Now the states is going to
be 0 2 0, and the branch
complexity is going to be --
there are three active
generators in the first half,
and three active generators
in the second half.
So by playing this kind of
game, which is called
sectionalization, we can make
the state complexity sometimes
appear simpler.
There are limits to how much
simpler we can make it.
Well, there actually aren't.
Suppose we took the whole eight
symbols as one time.
We'd have 0 dimensional state
space at the beginning, and 0
dimensional at the end.
What does that trellis
look like?
It looks like 16 parallel
transitions from
beginning to end.
That's a legitimate
trellis, right?
We should have one state at the
beginning and one state at
the end, and 16 transitions.
Is that what we get if
we went through this?
Yeah.
We have 0 0.
And what's the branch
complexity?
It's 4.
The dimension of the branch
space is 4 if we took the
whole thing.
So we can mask state complexity
by picking our
state spaces at appropriate
times, but you can't ever mask
branch complexity.
And again, it's a very
intuitive proof here.
Let's take this time here, where
there are three active
generators.
By expanding that time, can we
ever get fewer than three
active generators?
No, any interval that includes
this particular time is going
to have three active
generators in it.
So branch complexity cannot
be reduced by this kind of
sectionalization game.
State complexity can be
apparently reduced.
It isn't really.
But branch complexity cannot.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: And if you go too
far, it might increase.
So at the very end of the
chapter, I talk about
sectionalization.
It's not a very important
issue.
There's a very easy heuristic
for how you should
sectionalize, which is basically
you should make the
sections as big as you can
without increasing branch
complexity.
So in this case, the heuristic
says we know we're going to
have to have branch
complexity of 3.
But without increasing --
if I just make this one
partition at the center, I
just take these two sections,
first half, second half.
Then I have an increased
branch complexity.
So that's a good
sectionalization.
This will probably lead to the
simplest Viterbi algorithm and
the simplest-looking trellis
representation of the code.
So that's the character of the
sectionalization algorithm.
You can read about it.
It usually winds up with
a sensible time-varying
sectionalization, and it's
worth five minutes of
discussion.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it like a monotonic
kind of thing, like
if you make sections bigger,
then you'll only either
increase or keep the same
branch complexity?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that was my
basic argument, that if I have
any section that includes this
time, and I start making it
bigger, the dimension
can only increase.
So the algorithm is to keep
increasing it until I get to
some place where I might have to
include another generator.
For instance here, if I'm taking
this time, I don't want
to push it out over here,
because then I'll get the
fourth generator in there.
So any section that includes
time 3 should not be extended
in this direction, because we'll
get another generator.
But no problem with extending
in this direction.
So that's the basic heuristic.
It's easy.
And it's not very productive.
It doesn't really change the
complexity of the Viterbi
algorithm as a representation
of code.
So these are just a couple
of arguments to say
really we might --
the branch complexity
is more fundamental.
We want to focus on branch
complexity a little bit more.
But of course, if you have a
fully displayed trellis, the
maximum state space dimension is
either going to be equal to
the maximum branch space
dimension or one less than it.
Because in these binary
trellises, we get at most a
binary branch at each time.
So any branch complexity is
at most twice that of the
adjacent state space.
So they're not going to
differ by very much.
So state complexity is a good
proxy for branch complexity in
a fully displayed or
unsectionalized trellis.
While I'm on this subject,
there's another interesting
direction we can go, which is
average dimension bounds.
Again, think of our
realization here.
What does it contribute?
What does a single generator
contribute overall to state
and branch space complexity?
A single generator Gj of span
S, which of course has to be
greater than or equal to
the minimum distance
to the code, right?
The span can't be less
of a generator.
It can't be less than
the minimum nonzero
weight of any code word.
Span S contributes overall
to all the state space
dimensions.
It contributes S minus 1 state
space dimensions, because it's
active for S minus
1 state times.
And it contributes S branch
dimensions because it's active
for S symbols.
If I look at it spread out
across time, this generator of
span 4, it contributed three
times to a state space
dimension, and it
contributed four
times to a branch dimension.
So total state dimension has to
be greater than or equal to
k times d minus 1.
And the total branch dimension,
just summing up
across the trellis, is greater
than or equal to k
generators times d.
Now how many different
nontrivial
state spaces are there?
There are n minus 1 nontrivial
state times.
Excuse me.
For instance, in this code
of length 8, there are 7
nontrivial state spaces.
So the average state dimension
has to be greater than or
equal to k d minus
1 over n minus 1.
And the average branch dimension
has got to be
greater than or equal to k d
over the n symbol times.
So actually we might remember
that quantity.
That's what we called the coding
gain of the code, the
nominal coding gain on
the additive white
Gaussian noise channel.
Well, if the average dimension
is lower bounded by something,
then certainly the maximum state
space dimension is lower
bounded by that.
Max has to be at least as
great as the average.
So if these are what are called
the average dimension
bounds on the maximum state
space size, and there are some
interesting implications.
Again, this expression for
branch dimension is nicer
here, because it's
this k d over n
nominal coding gain thing.
It's in terms of the basic n
k d parameters of the code.
And it says what?
It says if you want a nominal
coding gain of 2, it implies
that the max branch dimension is
greater than or equal to 2.
Or the max size is greater than
or equal to 2 to the 2,
or you need a branch space of at
least size 4, or dimension
2 to get a 3 dB nominal
coding gain.
Similarly, if you want
a 6 dB gain --
let's get right down to dB.
It says you're going to need a
branch space size greater than
or equal to 4, or at least
a 16-state trellis.
So we know if we want a 6 dB
coding gain, we're going to
need at least a 16-state
trellis,
or a 16-branch trellis.
It might be an eight-state
trellis.
Well, these are not tight, but
they're quite indicative in
fact of what we see in both the
tables for block codes and
for convolutional codes.
These same bounds hold for
convolutional codes, by the
way, just average over
infinite time.
But they're still
perfectly good.
So they tell us that
in order to get --
if we want the nominal coding
gain to keep going up to 8, to
16, to infinity, it says we're
going to need infinite trellis
complexity to get infinite
coding gain.
Let's do some little
asymptotics, be a little bit
more refined about this.
A sequence of codes Cn of length
n going to infinity is
called good if both the rate k
over n is bounded away from 0
as n goes to infinity, and the
distance d over n is bounded
away from 0.
The rate and the relative
distance are both bounded away
from 0 as n goes to infinity.
Is that clear?
In other words, we want the
dimension and the minimum
distance both to increase
linearly with n in a good
sequence of codes.
This is a classical algebraic
definition, and it's easy to
prove there exists good
sequences of codes.
You just pick a code at random,
rate 1/2 of binary
linear code.
It on average will have
a relative minimum
distance about 11%.
This is just basic information
theory.
So there certainly exists
sequences of good codes, and
this is what most of coding
theory was occupied with
constructing for a
very long time.
What happens if you have a
good sequence of codes?
We have this nominal coding
gain, which is equal to kd
over n, which is equal to n
times k over n times d over n.
If both of these are bounded
away from zero, then the
nominal coding gain has to
increase linearly with n.
That means that the average,
or the maximum branch
dimension, in a minimal trellis
representation for
your code has to increase at
least linearly with n, which
means that the actual branch
complexity, the size of B, has
to increase as --
it goes as 2 to the nominal
coding gain, which is in other
words exponentially with n.
So basically what this says is
that if your objective is to
get a good sequence of codes,
if this is the way you think
you're going to get to channel
capacity, then sure enough,
your nominal coding gain
will go up to infinity
linearly with n.
But how are you going
to decode it?
Our first method was simply
maximum likelihood decoding.
The complexity of that,
computing the distance to
every code word, that
certainly goes up
exponentially with n, exhaustive
decoding, comparing
with every code word.
But now we have a new method
which is, we hope, simpler,
which is trellis decoding.
But we find out, unfortunately,
the complexity
of trellis decoding
is going to go up
exponentially with n as well.
So the good news was that with
the Viterbi algorithm and a
minimal trellis, we can get
a simpler optimum maximum
likelihood decoding algorithm
for block code, simpler than
exhaustive decoding.
The bad news is that under
this assumption, the
complexity of that algorithm
is still going to go up
exponentially with n.
Maybe just a lower exponent,
that's all.
So we haven't really solved our
basic problem, which is
exponential decoding complexity,
by going to
trellis decoding.
We have, however, another
way to go.
Do we really need the coding
gain to go to infinity, the
nominal coding gain
to go to infinity?
If we go back and remember the
name of the game, the playing
field that we're on, at least in
the additive white Gaussian
noise channel, we found the
distance between uncoded and
the Shannon limit was some
finite number, something like
9 dB at a 10 to the minus 5
error probability, larger at
lower error probability.
So that's the maximum
effective coding
gain we can ever get.
So maybe we only need a finite
nominal coding gain.
In practice, this means maybe
we don't need a minimum
distance that goes up
linearly with n.
Maybe we can have a very
long code with
a low minimum distance.
And that would be another
way to crack
the complexity problem.
In fact, some of the
capacity-approaching codes
that we're going to talk about,
specifically turbo
codes, tend to have bad
minimum distances.
You have a turbo code that's
thousands of bits long, and
its minimum distance will be
something like 20 or 30.
And yet it signals within 1
dB of the Shannon limit.
It gives you low error
probabilities within 1 dB of
the Shannon limit.
So maybe there's another way to
go, at least if we're only
interested in a certain
error probability.
Maybe it's 10 to the minus 5.
Maybe it's 10 to the minus 10.
But it's still only a finite
error probability.
Maybe we don't need the minimum
distance to go to infinity.
Maybe we can get by sampling
codes which are lousy in
classical terms, which have
poor minimum distance.
Maybe they'd be lousy in
distance terms, or in nominal
coding gain terms, but they'll
be very good from the point of
view of complexity.
Maybe there's some
trade-off here.
We know the code is going to
have to be long, but maybe it
doesn't have to have
large distance.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
That's what you are
saying, isn't it?
We try to maintain the --
PROFESSOR: We certainly want
to maintain a finite rate.
This was the problem with
orthogonal and simplex codes
and so forth, is that the rate
went to zero, and therefore
the spectral efficiency
went to zero.
In practically all cases,
that's unacceptable.
So we need to maintain some
minimal rate or spectral
efficiency on the additive
white Gaussian noise.
So that we need, but this
maybe we don't need.
So that's just a interesting
little bit of philosophy we
can do at this point, is how
should you really design
capacity-achieving codes?
And this seems to be a clue to
the way to go that has in fact
proved to be good.
However, I should add that not
all capacity-approaching codes
have this property.
A random low-density parity
check code is going to have
both low complexity and a very
good minimum distance as well.
So this certainly isn't
the full story.
There are just two more topics
in chapter 10, and maybe I'll
discuss them both briefly
right now.
One is I skipped over
projections.
And how shall I introduce
this subject?
I talked about the subcode of,
say, this code, which is
pretty badly marked-up by now,
but let me keep using it.
I talked about the subcode
that's supported, say, on the
first half.
In this case it's simply the
subcode that's generated by
the first generator.
Here's another code that we can
look at that's kind of a
first half code.
Suppose we just take the set
of all possible first
four-tuples in this code.
That's called the projection
onto the first half.
In other words, what are
the set of all possible
four-tuples?
They're the set of code words
that are generated by 1, 1, 1,
1, 0, 1, 0, 1, 0, 0,
1, 1, and this
doesn't contribute anything.
So it's a linear code.
It's length 4.
It has three generators,
dimension 3.
And we can quickly convince
ourselves that it's the even
weight, or zero sum, or
a single parity check
code of length 4.
So if we project this on
to the first half, we
get a 4, 3, 2 code.
So that's what I mean
by a projection.
If I project on to here,
I get the 1 0 code.
I'm sorry, I get the universe
code of length 1, all
one-tuples.
On here I get all two-tuples.
On here I get all
three-tuples.
But on here I don't get
all four-tuples.
I get a single parity
check code.
So those are my projections.
Some things can be done nicely
in terms of projections.
Projections are kind of
the dual to subcodes.
In fact, you prove this on the
homework in the course of
proving the dual state
space theorem.
In other words, the dual of a
subcode of a code C is the
projection of the dual code
of C, and vice versa.
They're always tongue twisters,
the duality theorem.
But that's what you will
prove along the way.
Let me give you the relevance
of this to
the state space theorem.
So I had the state space
theorem right here.
So let me leave it up.
State space theorem
is based on --
in general, we divide the
generator matrix g prime into
a part that is a generator
for the past subcode 0.
0 generator for the
future subcode.
And then some stuff down here,
which is generators of the
state space code.
By construction here, the
projections of any nonzero
vector in the state space
code are nonzero.
If they were zero, any nonzero
linear combination of these
generators down here cannot
be zero on here.
So the projection on to the
first half here, the dimension
of the projection --
I'm making a slight skip here
-- is basically equal to the
dimension of the past subspace
code plus the dimension of the
state code.
It's basically generated by
these generators and these
generators projected
onto here.
We can forget about
these generators.
So let me write that down.
The dimension of C projected
onto the past is equal to the
dimension of the past subcode
plus the dimension of the
state space code.
Which leads to another version
of the state space theorem.
I could simply write state space
theorem as dimension of
the state space at time k is
simply the difference between
the dimension of the projection,
C projected on the
past, minus the dimension
of the subcode.
It's all of these guys
minus these guys.
And again, if we look back here,
we see we have the 4, 3
code is C projected on
p, 4, 3, 2, and C --
the subcode is 4, 1, 4.
In fact, for this, these are
both Reed-Muller codes of half
the length.
This is not an accident,
as you will
prove in the homework.
The state space size is the
difference in the dimensions
of these two codes.
This is a very handy thing
to know, and you're
going to need this.
This, for instance, will give
you that in general for
Reed-Muller codes, if you
divide them in half --
we had this general picture of
say the 8 4 code being made up
by the new u plus
v construction.
These two together make
the 8, 4, 4 code.
If you have the u u plus v
construction, there you are,
first half, second half.
You will find that the
projection on the first half
is always this guy, which
is the u code.
And the subcode is v code,
which is the homework.
And so you can quickly read
off from this what the
dimension of the central
state space is
for Reed-Muller codes.
In this case it's 2.
But for instance if we have the
32, 16, 8 code, then what
is that made up of?
That's made up from the
16, 11, 4 code and
the 16, 5, 8 code.
And so we can see the dimension
of the central state
space here is going to be 6.
We're going to get a 64-state
trellis for this code, at
least just measuring the size
of the central state space.
Now it turns out you
can keep having --
if you go down and you make
four cuts here, then the
relevant codes are what you
get one more space back.
At this space, we have the 2,
2, 1 as the projected code,
and the 2, 0, infinity
as the subcode.
And again, the difference in
dimensions here is going to be
the same as the different
dimensions here.
Minor miracle at first.
It turns out to be just
from the construction.
Here we go back to the 8,
7, 2 and the 8, 1, 8.
And again we see the difference
here is 6.
So that means that Reed-Muller
codes always have trellises,
least if you put them
in four sections.
They always look like
this abstractly.
They look like what
we've already seen
for the 8, 4, 4 code.
And you'll do this on the
homework using projections.
That's not very hard.
It doesn't mean that --
so we know, for instance, for
the 32 16 8, we're going to do
this, and there are going to be
64 states here, 64 states
here, 64 states here.
We don't know what it's going to
be in between, but you can
figure that out too.
In fact, we get a minimal
trellis for the whole thing.
That's what you need
to do the homework.
There are actually two more
topics that I want to do in
Chapter 10.
One is the Muder bound.
And one --
I actually want to see how
good are these block code
trellises vis-a-vis
convolutional code trellises.
So I'll do both of those at the
beginning of next time.
For homework problem set, let's
this week do only the
first four problems.
So for this Wednesday,
do problem set --
what are we up to?
Seven, is it?
One through four, and for
Wednesday, 4/20, we'll do
problem set seven, five and six,
plus I'll probably have
another one.
But we have a holiday next
Monday also if you recall,
Patriots' Day.
So we only get one more
class on Wednesday.
So I probably won't have much
more to add than this.
Is that clear?
Maybe Ashish you could
put out a email to
the class to do that.
So good.
We'll come back and clean
up Chapter 10 quickly on
Wednesday, and then
move on to 11.